(bright music)
- My name's Mike Perry.
I'm working on a special,
crazy first time animated
episode of Broad City.
I've been doing the
titles for years now,
and it's been really fun
to be a part of the project
since the beginning.
(rap music)
- Open animation, it's not
separate from the show,
it is part of the
Broad City world.
Mike Perry, he also has kind
of become our visual brand.
- You know the relationship
with the titles versus
what I'm doing now for episode
404, is very different.
The episode involves
live action world,
transitioning into
cartoon world.
The fully animated part
is about eight minutes,
so we have to take the
viewer on a journey from
before they consume to when
they're getting their buzz on,
to where they're
tripping their face off,
just wandering glowing canyons.
- We had written him this
whole list of background jokes,
about like 10 pages of it.
You have to watch it so many
times to get all the jokes.
There's a guy skateboarding
along the street,
but it's pancakes.
- Yeah, he's on a pad of
butter, skating on a pancake.
(bright music)
- Every season they put one
of their PAs in the background
just jerking off on the street.
So we've been requested to put
him into our animated world.
- Is it weird my
nipples are sore?
- No that is perfectly normal.
- Mine are bleeding
(cat squealing)
- One of the things that
I personally think about,
when I think about
mushrooms as a drug,
is how often it fills you
with a level of warmth
and positivity, and also
feminine and glowing,
and so it was really great
opportunity to get into that
in this drawing, and
having it be saturated with
really beautiful
moment, if animated.
- You really feel like
you're with the girls,
tripping with them, increasing
the trip, decreasing
and then doing the stupid
thing of adding weed too early.
(blowing out)
- I am feeling that the weed...
- Mmm.
- I mostly sketched out
everything on paper,
I cannot iterate how
important the sketchbook
part of the process is for me.
Oh here we go, this is one
of the first drawings I did.
This mother is flying
with the babies
hanging from their breasts.
- That's comic book shit.
- So a lot of this stuff
starts in the books
and the finds its way into the
appropriate part of the world
this is a possible cut
out for the music scene.
Abby and Alana are
basically playing the city
as though it's
like an orchestra,
and so this would just be
kind of like a cut shot,
to this scene of jamming out
as the whole city jams out.
- You could tell how much
fun he had making this,
and it's so, I cannot
wait for people to see it.
- I love you man.
- I love you too, man.
(electric music)